March is almost upon us, and just like every
month, a truckload of new offerings will be
dropping on Netflix.
There's something for everyone coming to the
streaming site in March 2020, but if you happen
to be a big fan of prestige dramas, romantic
comedies, or both, you're really in luck.
While the action-packed offerings arriving
on Netflix in March 2020 are just a little
bit thin, there's still a few flicks sure
to get your adrenaline pumping.
For some pulse-pounding action, check out
Haywire, a 2011 actioner directed by Steven
Soderbergh, known for entertaining films such
as Magic Mike and Logan Lucky.
Haywire features an absolutely sterling cast,
led by Gina Carano, who you may recognize
from her ass-kicking turns in Deadpool and
the Disney+ series The Mandalorian.
Carano stars as Mallory Kane, a dangerous
government operative who finds herself targeted
by her own shady employers.
The supporting cast includes Michael Fassbender,
Ewan McGregor, Channing Tatum.
Michael Douglas, Antonio Banderas, and the
late, great Bill Paxton.
Also on tap in March is Cop Out, a buddy cop
comedy which stars the intriguingly weird
duo of Bruce Willis and Tracy Morgan; Hook,
a 1991 Steven Spielberg-directed fantasy which
focuses on an adult Peter Pan, played by Robin
Williams, and his titular nemesis, played
by Dustin Hoffman; and the 2004 theatrical
adaptation of Lemony Snicket's A Series of
Unfortunate Events, which stars Jim Carrey
as the villainous Count Olaf.
All of these hit the streaming service on
March 1.
You want dramas?
Netflix has got dramas.
March 1 alone brings a wealth of hard-hitting
fare, including a pair of excellent mob flicks
in Donnie Brasco , starring Al Pacino and
Johnny Depp, and Martin Scorsese's masterpiece
GoodFellas.
Also dropping on March 1 is the Oscar-nominated
Stephen King adaptation The Shawshank Redemption
and the Paul Thomas Anderson-directed There
Will Be Blood, which earned its star Daniel
Day-Lewis an Academy Award for Best Actor.
"I drink your milkshake.
I drink it up!"
On March 16, you can check out Silver Linings
Playbook, which nabbed star Jennifer Lawrence
an Academy Award for Best Actress.
March 16 also brings the Cold War drama Tinker
Tailor Soldier Spy to the streaming giant,
which sports a ridiculous cast including Gary
Oldman, Tom Hardy, Colin Firth , Benedict
Cumberbatch, and John Hurt.
Finally, March 27 brings the vastly underrated
2012 neo-noir Killing Them Softly, which centers
on a trio of small-time hoods on the run from
a pair of mob hit men portrayed by Brad Pitt
and the late James Gandolfini.
Rom-com fans have a lot to look forward to
in March 2020.
Premiering on Netflix on the first of the
month alone are Always a Bridesmaid, starring
Javicia Leslie; Ghosts of Girlfriends Past,
with Matthew McConaughey; and He's Just Not
That Into You, which features an all-star
cast including Jennifer Aniston, Ben Affleck,
Scarlett Johansson, Bradley Cooper, Jennifer
Connolly, and Justin Long.
Also premiering on March 1 are Life As We
Know It, starring Katherine Heigl [HIGH-gull]
and Josh Duhamel [DOO-mel]; and Sleepover,
which features Alexa Vega, Steve Carell, Evan
Peters, and a pre-superstardom Brie Larson.
And while it arrives a little late for the
actual holiday, you can also catch the Garry
Marshall-directed Valentine's Day on March
1, starring Ashton Kutcher, Taylor Swift,
Julia Roberts, Bradley Cooper, and Jennifer
Garner.
"Good evening."
Plus, March 1 brings the 1982 Dustin Hoffman
classic Tootsie, which co-stars Bill Murray
and Geena Davis and was directed by the great
Sydney Pollack.
Fans of Bugs Bunny and his pals are also in
for a treat in March 2020, as a pair of awesome
selections will hit Netflix on March 1.
You'll be able to catch the 1996 live-action
and animation mashup Space Jam, as well as
the underrated, hilarious 2003 Brendan Fraser
starrer Looney Tunes: Back in Action.
Netflix will field an absolutely paltry new
crop of horror and thriller releases in March
2020.
If you dig the Resident Evil series, you'll
find 2004's Apocalypse and 2007's Extinction
available for streaming on the first of the
month, and they account for two of the three
new offerings for the month in total.
The third, however, is the very definition
of an underrated gem: Sam Raimi's 2000 psychological
horror flick The Gift.
The movie stars Cate Blanchett
as Annie, a small-town psychic and widow who
foresaw her own husband's death.
She begins to have similarly disturbing visions
involving her best friend Valerie, whose abusive
husband Donnie is a looming presence in her
visions.
Keanu Reeves plays Donnie, delivering a performance
completely unlike anything you have ever seen
out of him before, while Oscar-winner Hilary
Swank plays Valerie.
The Gift was Raimi's last film before tackling
the seminal superhero flick Spider-Man, and
it's fun to see J.K. Simmons and Rosemary
Harris — who would go on to portray J. Jonah
Jameson and Aunt May, respectively in minor
roles here.
If you're a fan of tight, tense thrillers,
you owe it to yourself to check this flick
out.
As is usually the case, Netflix will be offering
up a few intriguing standup sets during March
2020.
On March 3, check out Quarter-Life Crisis,
the first solo special from Taylor Tomlinson.
"All my friends are like you need a guy with
a car, and a job, and I'm like yeah but then
I've gotta deal with his wife, like, it's
a whole thing."
She may be only 25, but she's seemingly been
plying her trade forever, and has been a regular
on the late night talk show circuit since
making her TV debut on Last Comic Standing
in 2015.
March 10 will see the release of End Times
Fun, the new special from Marc Maron; you
may recognize him as the host of the WTF with
Marc Maron podcast, or perhaps via his appearances
in feature films like Sword of Trust and Joker.
He also starred in his own eponymous sitcom,
Maron, from 2013-2016 on the IFC network,
and he currently stars as Sam Sylvia on the
hit Netflix series GLOW.
Finally, on March 17, you can catch Hey Big
Boy, the latest standup set from notorious
party dude Bert Kreischer.
In case you're not familiar with his comedic
aesthetic, just know that in 1997, Kreischer
was featured in a Rolling Stone article in
which he was designated the "top partier at
the Number One Party School in the country,"
Florida State University.
Kreischer's exploits were the basis for the
classic comedy feature Van Wilder, the movie
which helped to make Ryan Reynolds a household
name.
Last but not least, Netflix will be offering
a small but scintillating selection of new
television seasons in March 2020.
The long-awaited third season of the hit animated
series Castlevania will premiere on March
5, followed by a slightly more irreverent
animated offering season 2 of the hilarious
Paradise PD on March 6.
Also dropping that day is season 2 of Ugly
Delicious, the fascinating documentary-slash-cooking
show-slash-travelogue hosted by the genially
charismatic chef David Chang.
March 17 will bring us season 2 of the CW
sports drama All American and season 3 of
that network's superhero series Black Lightning,
which has at long last been established to
have a connection to the shows of the Arrowverse
via the recent, massive crossover event 'Crisis
on Infinite Earths.'
Finally, March 27 will see the release of
season 3 of Ozark, the Jason Bateman-starring
crime drama which has kept fans waiting for
about a year and a half for new episodes.
Bateman portrays Marty Byrde, a crooked financial
planner who relocates his family from Chicago
to Missouri after a money laundering scheme
blows up in his face.
Unfortunately for him, he's indebted to a
Mexican drug cartel, and things don't get
any less tense after the family's move.
If you haven't yet caught Ozark, now would
be a good time to catch up on the first two
seasons, which are pretty great.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.